où vont blanchemaison expert en
relations internationales reconcevoir
fêtes danses maison merci d'être avec
nous pour évoquer également cette
actualité
la journée parce qu'on va tâcher d'y
voir plus clair dans cette affaire qui
semble invraisemblable
pourquoi la biélorussie at elle pris
cette décision selon vous de détourner
un avion et pourquoi hier mais je crois
que le président alexandre loukachenko
l'a fait sciemment en connaissance de
cause alors la première la première
chose c'est que en faisant atterrir cet
avion et en arrêtant ses décidant qu'ils
avaient trouvé un asile politique en
lituanie eh bien il signifie à tous ses
opposants à tous les opposants à son
régime
où qu'ils soient il y en a beaucoup en
pologne lituanie en effet qui ne sont à
l'abri de rien que tout peut leur
arriver et qui ne sont pas en sécurité
ça c'est le premier point le deuxième
point je crois que le président
alexandre loukachenko dans le fonds
prend le set 7 cette occasion il a fait
atterrir cet avion de force sachant
pertinemment que ceci provoquerait des
protestations énergiques de tous les
pays occidentaux est probablement la
décision de sanctions de la part de la
plupart des pays occidentaux ce qui de
son point de vue élargirait le fossé
entre les pays occidentaux et l'alliance
entre la russie la biélorussie alliance
à laquelle il attache la plus grande
importance parce que c'est sa seule
bouée de sauvetage au bout du compte et
il voit mal la russie le désavouer et
puis effectivement cette affaire de
messages du hamas disant qu'il y avait
une bombe et ben là encore il faut faire
authentifier ce message il ya vraiment
un message du havre du hamas il doit
pouvoir être authentifié par les
spécialistes ça doit ça devrait être
possible mais personne n'y croit
véritablement et c'est bien ça le
problème
mais je crois que monsieur loukachenko
s'en moque un petit peu parce que si la
cie cet événement s'est produit hier
c'est parce qu'aussi aujourd'hui ce soir
c'est l'arrêt
du conseil européen et que monsieur le
cachet coup s'est ainsi invitée à la
table du conseil européen on devait
discuter de sujets très sérieux on
devait discuter de la sortie de la
pandémie de la stratégie de vaccination
dans l'union européenne du passeport
vaccinale pour rétablir la liberté de
circulation à l'intérieur de l'union
européenne
on devait aussi parler d'ailleurs des
rapports futurs avec la russie des
rapports avec le royaume-uni débreak
site est évidemment tout va se
concentrer en tout cas dans un premier
temps sur cette affaire est intervenue
hier soir et qui paraît tout à fait un
malaise alors monsieur k seco sait aussi
pertinemment que les états membres sont
divisés et que ça sera sans doute
difficile d'aboutir à l'unanimité pour
décider de nouvelles sanctions
il ya déjà des sanctions suite à
l'élection présidentielle contestée du
mois d'août dernier 88 personnalités
biélorusses sont sanctionnées c'est à
dire que elles n'ont pas accès à des
visas pour les pays de l'union
européenne elle ne peut pas d'avoir
d'avoirs financiers dans ces pays ça
n'est pas très grave puisque aucun de
ses 88 personnage n'avait l'intention de
passer ses vacances en europe
et s'il y avait des comptes dans les
banques de l'union européenne
ces comptes sont partis depuis très
longtemps dans les directions asiatiques
mais effectivement il est question
aujourd'hui de mettre davantage de
sanctions
claude le sommet de l'union européenne à
député débuté tout à l'heure son ordre
du jour quelque peu été évidemment
chamboulé par cette affaire l'europe qui
semble quand même clairement prendre la
chose très au sérieux
oui parce que en effet les expressions
très très très très dur ont été utilisés
piraterie étatique terrorisme étatique
est effectivement la plupart des
institutions sont se sont émus de cette
possibilité pour un état de faire
atterrir de force à un avion pour au
bout du compte
récupérer un de ses nationaux qui avait
reçu l'asile diplomatique dans un autre
pays par la cie diplomatique à des
politiques dans un autre pays
donc c'est difficilement acceptable pour
les états de l'union européenne et il va
y avoir une discussion sur la conduite à
tenir
monsieur loukachenko est persuadé qu'il
n'y a pas d'unanimité pour appliquer des
sanctions
peut-être se trompe-t-il peut-être ce
tranquille on verra ça d'ici demain
mais il ya différentes catégories de
sanctions en effet on peut allonger la
liste et 90 personnes déjà sanctionné
même si c'est un peu symbolique comme je
l'aï dit tout à l'heure on peut aussi
comme l'a proposé la belgique interdire
à la la société d'aviation nationale de
d'atterrir sur les aéroports de l'union
européenne on peut aussi aller un peu
plus loin en évident amant en
restreignant la circulation à travers
entre les frontières de la biélorussie
et l'union européenne
cela dit c'est un jeu un peu dangereux
parce que il n'est pas l'intérêt de
l'union européenne de restreint des
mouvements de population entre la
biélorussie et l'europe
les contacts entre les populations
civiles sont souhaitables
c'est dans l'intérêt de la grande europe
et puis il vient aussi un problème
particulier avec le territoire russe qui
se trouve être le territoire de
kaliningrad et qui en fait est enclavée
à l'intérieur de deux pays européens que
sont la lituanie et la pologne et à
l'époque où la lituanie et la pologne
sont rentrés dans l'union européenne on
a négocié avec la russie l'union
européenne a négocié avec la russie de
façon à assurer la liberté de
circulation des russe de kaliningrad et
des russes du reste de la russie et la
liberté aussi de circulation des
marchandises et de toutes sortes
d'équipements
alors il ne faudrait pas qu'en voulant
contrôler la frontière de vielles russie
ont re met encore en cause cet accord
était finalement tout
fait essentiel à l'intégrité de la
russie donc c'est un sujet très délicat
très sensible sur lequel le conseil
européen prendra sans doute une décision
de principe
probablement plus symbolique que réelle
et puis enfin comme ça a été dit tout à
l'heure
l'organisation de l'aviation civile
internationale dont le siège est à
montréal dans tous les pays font partie
est chargé d'assurer la liberté de tous
les vols de tous les vols civils et qui
par conséquent doit mener une enquête
alors on vient d'annoncer que l'oaci
convoque une réunion pour jeudi
pourquoi je dis et pourquoi pas demain
il est essentiel de faire la lumière sur
les éléments factuels que s'est-il
produit réellement si tel ce quelles
indications at on décidé de cet
atterrissage forcé d'un avion civil de
sa d'un avion de ryanair qui faisait la
liaison entre athènes et venus de villes
de pays qui appartiennent à l'union
européenne
et pourquoi at on arrêté ce passager qui
certes est un dissident en biélorussie
mais qui est aussi un réfugié politique
en lituanie par conséquent je crois que
loin s'il doit absolument faire très
rapidement la lumière et il ya des
règles à appliquer il ya une convention
de chicago qui régit la liberté des vols
civils et qui probablement a été violée
dans ce cas particulier
merci beaucoup claude blanchou maison